[Musique]
des questions comme ce cyclo duplessis
il répond cinq jours par semaine 6 1
éclipse de lune
il n'y a pas de danger un la lune on
peut l'observer sans protection la lune
elle ne fait que refléter la lumière du
soleil elles reflètent environ 29%
jusqu'en avril les élèves de 600 classes
du québec ont droit à ce cadeau virtuel
de l'astrolab du mont mégantic une
rencontre de 45 minutes très populaire
toujours agréable de les voir réagir à
chaque foyer ou des questions année fini
ça fait longtemps qu'on rêvait de mettre
plus d'énergie sur les activités à
distance d'amener notre émerveillement
cosmique directement à la maison de
partager le mont mégantic avec les gens
chez eux et ça fonctionne
au delà des espérances plus de deux
millions de participants depuis le début
de la pandémie est obligé de modifier
nos structures de de faire un deuxième
studio si on veut de communication en
direct donc la maintenance etc jusqu'à
huit bureaux à distance par jour qu'on
fait
pourquoi on appelle ça des étoiles
filantes mais c'est vraiment belle
aventure et on est très très contents de
d'apporter notre contribution nous aussi
dans cette période sont assez
particulières qu'on est tous en train de
vivre
pour réaliser ce défi technologique il
fallait au télescope à la hauteur d'un
télescope qui a été vraiment a semblé
modifier pour pour faire des images en
direct du ciel étoilé pissos pour nous
c'est vraiment une révolution on est
capable en une fraction de seconde à
voir des images de galaxies ou de
nébuleuse très lointaine et de les
montrer en couleurs en direct avec des
explications à n'importe qui partout
dans l'astral aux avis de saint jacques
a aussi beaucoup à voir dans l'intérêt
accru des canadiens vers l'astronomie et
c'est certain que ça lui n'est pas parce
que c'est très médiatisé puis lorsqu'il
revient sur ta c'est la même chose dans
les médias vont en parler beaucoup alors
sa voix et florence et beaucoup les
jeunes
madame emilie ici jean arel radio-canada
notre dame des bois